welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Game of Thrones is back with its
penultimate battle that sees the forces
of Westeros facing down against Cersei
and the golden company there's a lot to
unpack from this and there are huge
indicators of where the season will be
going for its finale next week and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about episode 5 as well as what it could
lead to down the line this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
their latest release then I highly
suggest that you turn off now but
without the way I hope you enjoyed the
video now sit back relax and let's get
into my ending explain breakdown of Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 5 as always
let's start with a quick recap of
episode for the night Kings forces are
no more Varys insisted that Jon Snow
should be the rightful king the Game of
Thrones prop guy got fired after someone
left a coffee cup on the table we know
it was you Sansa and missandei ended up
missin day head off her body so drive
picks up with the Battle of King's
Landing and it's a hell of an episode
this is flat-out carnage and not the
kind that was teased at the end of venom
in that terrible terrible post-credit
scene anyway look Varys has betrayed
Dany and chose Jon Snow is the true king
of the north and this episode was pretty
much a confirmation of his worst fears
Varys was one episode away from retiring
but after it's revealed of his
treacherous ways the character is burned
alive now it's pretty clear that D&D
have settled on the Mad Queen archetype
so depending on how much that you agree
with it it will either make this episode
amazing or just plain terrible Dany
won't see sense at all even when Tyrion
tries to convince her otherwise and it's
clear that the character is seeing
enemies everywhere
Jon tries to dissuade her but like tatty
and James Charles she's having none of
it
flaming sands eff embarrasses death and
deciding that fear is the best way to
rule in case you haven't guessed it
she's the bad guy even when discussing
the other bad guys see Danny tries to
justify this
as she say she's removing a tyrant and
that those at King's Landing should be
happy that she's doing a great job
Tyrion begs the character to call off
her armies and states that if the bells
ring then it's a surrender which Dany
pays about as much attention to as the
writers have the reviews of this final
season omits the soldiers preparing for
the bloodthirsty battle area and the
Hound arrived at camp and though these
guys are ready for the next fight
they're also pretty excited that someone
else is here to finish the job so that
they can go home early to their
girlfriend oh wait Jamie has been
captured at this point and Tyrion visits
him and after the to talk it's decided
that Cersei won't give up like the
diehard fans aren't giving up from the
show even though this season has been
worse than the latest Walking Dead and
Tyrion frees him
the two make a tearful goodbye and it's
pretty clear that it will be a miracle
if both of them manage to make it to the
finale next week and thus the battle
begins the iron fleet is out in full
force and operation human shield is in
full effect below the armaments Jaime is
trying to sneak into the castle but we
don't really have time for that and the
battle begins with Dany swooping in to
basically Massacre the town everything
gets completely destroyed including
everyone's favorite golden company
leader who feels like he had his entire
story arc left on the cutting-room floor
of a better season in the red keep
Cersei stays optimistic but it quickly
turns into the hit limine that went
about a couple of years ago with her
forces dwindling massively the soldiers
dropped their swords quicker than the
Rotten Tomatoes scores on the season and
it seems like it's all over the bells of
surrender ring and we can finally go
home right wrong
Dany is in full Mad Queen mode and like
proud marry she keeps on burnin a burnin
burnin down the road God I'm really
sorry the jokes are in this episode I'm
sorry anyway it doesn't matter if he
says C or just some guy who works at
McDonald's everyone is a target and this
even inspires Danny's men to stop
participating in the
war-crimes searcy realizing things are
turning a bit disco inferno decides to
get the hell out of there whilst you Ron
and Jamie bump into one another in an
awkward I had sex with his sister so did
i standoff this leads to Jamie getting
stabbed and yuan getting stabbed back in
the process with him uttering I got you
I am the man that killed Jamie Lannister
which if you've seen the rest of the
episode you know it's not the case
meanwhile the hound and Arya have made
their way to the red key the hound was
on his way to bring down the mountain an
area was on a way to take another name
off their list but due to Danny's attack
the location begins to crumble in what
feels like a final farewell at the Hound
Ward's area off revenge and goes ahead
to face his brother this is one of the
biggest grudge matches in the entire
show and it doesn't disappoint after an
unmasking that looks like they're
setting up the mountain to replace Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool the Hound realizes
that his brother isn't dying the easy
way and thus has to sacrifice himself in
order to take them both out the to
tumble off the cape and fall to their
fiery deaths which probably would have
been the biggest death in the episode if
it wasn't for the next view with herself
at a loss Cersei begins wandering
through the castle which is when she's
reunited with Jaime who seems to be her
only way out of this
the two flee to the basement and trying
to escape together however when they
reach the bottom they find their escape
is blocked and the two died side-by-side
crushed under their own way of their
failings literally which even on its own
fields like the bittersweet ending for
the show that we've all been hoping for
with the war over we survey the damage
in a damn girl I didn't know you could
get that freaky moment that sees Dany as
the true villain we were rooting for you
Danny
we were all rooting for you and
obviously that sets up the next episode
which we all know going ahead that
Daenerys is going to be the mad Queen
and though John seems pretty loyal to
her as he's still in the honeymoon phase
and hasn't realized how crazy his new
girlfriend is the Starks will have a
huge say over this
I think the choice will come down to
being between Sansa and Dany for John
with the latter urging him that he's not
even really their family and shouldn't
have any loyalty towards them this will
make the final episode rather dramatic
instead of action-packed like this one
and I can see it causing a lot of
for the character who probably just
wants to be done with his whole thing
either way it's setting up for an
amazing finale and I can't wait to see
who ends up on the throne and the final
few minutes of the show obviously I
loved hear your thoughts on this episode
and if you like the direction that the
show's taking for its final few episodes
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out my
full breakdown of every episode in the
season so far which you'll be linked at
the end this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for take the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]